especially when you're a teenager like
my teen years were pretty bad and I was
always just like like the wall of not
understanding why your parents are doing
things you're just mad about it is like
pretty strong and I think like once it
breaks down it's like those years are
over already anyway like I'm out of the
house when I became a parent I was like
damn my parents are extra
[Music]
stupid so welcome back to careful boys
today we're talking about what
are some things that most people
discover when it is too late crypto true
sorry we were just on that one that's
true Financial education yeah that's a
good one dude that's a good one I think
it's like a a lot of information and
it's it's a journey that probably should
be started at like early childhood
especially if you're like take a long
time to learn things like me and [__]
and then like um I also think like they
don't teach you in a way where it's more
about emotional and self-control and
discipline it's displine rather than um
I Heard low blood pressure like it's not
taught in the way where it's like you
have to do this as a behavioral thing
it's more like it's more like here's
some step-by-step methods on saving
money or like how to like use a credit
card and it's very technical but I think
they should approach Financial education
the way that they would teach a kid how
to maybe manage their emotions
I think that's how they should approach
it interesting cuz like for me I'm like
I think I know everything and then I
blow my money on the wrong all the time
and I'm like why did I do that that's
because you're a badass I don't even
like that brand man no you're you're a
legend though I don't want to be it's
just yeah you're pretty but you are I'm
like that guy that's like surfing and
then has no like responsibilities and
everyone goes look at I want to be like
that guy and I'm like but I don't have
stability in my life let me you ride the
waves yeah you're like oh that guy's
living life I
know yeah dud before you know it you're
like a 60-year-old dude in the ocean and
then it's like oh you're like a hasb
been rock star dude one of my favorite
examples of this what you're talking
about financial management is when Bart
was on [__] Graham Stefan show and
Graham Stefan the whole time is just
like you did what oh my [__] god oh
my [__] god he had a heart attack
listening to how you spend money he's
like we should just blow up the human RS
let where's the asteroid just let let it
hit just kill us but the my favorite
part is he actually lived up to Bart's
dream of being a fitness influencer he
did he really did he didn't know that
Bart did any comedy or anything oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah he didn't know anything
about JK even the title was bodybuilder
he went by the bit that I was saying the
whole time here in JK dude nobody sees
you as that [__] they all just sees a
[__] like Fitness
Guru no one sees you as a comedian
Bart's like yeah right he's like Bart's
like I'm silly I'm I dance sometimes
when I Work It
Out grab St is like you're like a
bodybuilder guy what's up with that
that's a title but the whole comments
were like you know a lot of JK fans that
also watch it they're like oh my God
Steve's Fitness bodybuilding dying dude
they were laughing so [__] funny but
you i' never seen that guyy all the
blood rush out of his whole head yeah
cuz he's a very responsible finan you
troubled him dude
he was like you're crazy yeah you you
had him questioning his whole [__]
life yeah I think the funny part about
all that though is like we're not even
understanding what kind of dangerous
moves we're doing so we're just going by
life like oh yeah it happened and
they're like you [__] idiot how do
you keep getting lucky you know true I
think tax is also one of those things
that you don't learn until it's too
[__] tax tax can eat a dick bro
that's such a catch 22 cuz I feel like
when they teach you about it you're like
get away from me you [__] loser so
boring cuz they teach you how to pay
them cuz I feel like they teach you like
what like like senior year right like an
econ or whatever yeah they're just
teaching you how to pay them and file
them that's different and then later on
you're like oh [__] I think I should
have paid attention or something they
don't teach you how to come out on top
of it though they just teach you how to
comply well most people don't ever have
to learn about it right cuz then you're
if you're just like if yeah if you're on
a W2 then everything is taken care of
for you your taxes get paid first so
then you never have to think about it or
worry about but you can still you can
still play the game though yeah you can
still play the game as a W2 employee and
figure out how to maximize either your
savings or your refunds or just whatever
the [__] like programs and stuff like or
like if you become a homeowner or yeah
or like your 401k like I found out
[__] like way later on your
retirement like let's say you have hell
of money in there I think in the state
of California you can pull it out and
use it
for I think up to 60 days and then as
long as you put it back in um you won't
get penalized for it so you're loaning
your own money yeah so there's just like
[__] like that there's like so many
loopholes that we just don't even know
how to take advantage of so if you had a
four Shir deal and like let's you had
500 G's or something in your in your uh
retirement and you needed to do
something like you could potentially use
that and then if you KNE you're going to
flip it within 60 days and you just put
the money back in and still come up and
there's just so much [__] and then if
you also know that too just knowing that
hey if you like work at a certain job
where your employer will match your 401k
uh contributions then just being like
max out your contribution somebody's
willing to Max it out with you you know
what I'm saying because it's not like
locked in there you could still leverage
it you can still borrow against it or
you still access it for a penalty but
somebody else is paying just as much as
you are it's like how do you take
advantage of that nobody sits to you
down and like make sure you do this
because that's the right answer there
are right answers to that financial
literacy you know that's true but but
you don't [__] know that until it's
like somebody your buddy's been doing it
for like 10 years it's not sexy until
you hit the roadblock and you need that
information Finance if finances and [__]
and taxes and all that it was like
skateboarding you have to break your arm
before you do the first move yeah what
was an AA moment for you a aha moment
yeah the first one was uh I think when
me and Joe first formed the LLC mhm and
uh so our financial advisor is like our
is on Joe's side of the family and he
was like we're like oh so when do we
need to like create like a legit entity
to do whatever and then he was like in
the state of California he goes um you
technically don't have to until I think
he said it was like 70k or something at
that time and they're like okay for sure
we make way under that right now and
then he was like but even if you do make
past that since you guys don't make
actual like materials like like clothing
or whatever like the chances of someone
suing you is very very low cuz you're
making comedy like so it's not like they
can like buy something and get a crazy
skin rash he was like there's you
probably don't necessarily have to pay
this uh incorporation fee until way
later on and that was the first big
mind-blowing um moment because it wasn't
about what is the law it's more so about
how do you like mitigate risk and how do
you play this game cuz he's like
technically if you made 100 GS a year
you should file LLC but the point of the
LLC is to protect you but if you don't
need protection then why would you do it
and it was just like a way a completely
way different way of thinking that I was
like what the [__] yeah and that kind of
opened up like the the like rabbit hole
of like okay so if there's that then
what else and what else and what else
yeah yeah I remember like maybe like N9
years ago or some [__] like that I
remember thinking like I had a good year
and I was like dude I made like 75 grand
this year from work or whatever right
right and then I had no I didn't have a
personal LLC I didn't have like any
financial literacy with taxes and stuff
like that I wasn't working with the CPA
specifically I was kind of just like
figuring out how to file stuff myself
with little [__] reimbursement sheets
that you find on Google and whatnot
right and then I had I owed the [__]
IRS like 30 grand but I didn't know how
to like attack that and the crazy when
you feel like you're like oh I had like
my best financial year I earned this
because like I worked my ass off and
then everything that you card to save
for that entire year Suddenly by April
you're paying it off and borrowing money
to pay the rest oh my God you get so
like f the man yeah that I I remember
the next like week here's the funny
thing on the one hand I started like
youtubing and understanding as much I
could learning as much about finances
and tax as possible and on the other
hand I like in order to F the man I was
like [__] only streaming movies and
not paying the
be just downloading torent and [__]
anything at a time you know what I'm
saying just like that feeling of like
man [__] it like if I'm going to lose
money you're going to lose
money I feel like the first time we had
to pay like six figures in taxes that's
when I started looking at the city and
going like why is there a [__] crack
on this road yeah I'm all like why is
why are you guys mismanaging funds and
then I got more and more angry when I
saw news about like they're about to
build this [__] train and never
happened and then you start seeing like
people getting in trouble for corruption
this guy was mismanaging funds this
politician was buying a [__]
Lamborghini and then that [__] started
pissing me off cuz it felt like why are
we paying all this tax money when these
guys are just stealing it yeah and then
they're not even helping like if I saw
our communities like thriving you know
poor people are like being helped out
you see people all having a quality of
Education healthare all that then I'm
like yeah like I can see see how this is
going somewhere and it's helping the
society but I don't see it like
everywhere we're looking it's like that
[__] light needs to be replaced man
it hasn't been working in like 10 years
or like I don't know it just it just
feels like where's the money going yeah
and then they need more and more money
and I'm like why and they always raised
funds for the Department of of Education
in California yeah and they always have
the worst scores so it's like but if we
only we had more money and like I feel
bad for the teachers I know the teachers
need more money do I think that but if
you ever talk to one you know they do
and they're not the ones getting paid
though correct the Department of
Education is so [__] like corrupt as
[__] that's the thing I learned the most
cuz I have some family Who's involved in
that stuff it's like wild even in the
good school districts even like the rich
school districts these people aren't
getting paid enough and then you find
out more about how the racket works like
you know governments they get the it
they have this use it or lose it funding
mentality right so like let's say you
get a budget of like $100,000 and then
you would think you get rewarded for
going hey we only spent 30,000 this year
so we actually have a a surplus in the
budget for another 70,000 but if you do
that oh well you only need to operate
with $330,000 we're only going to give
you $30,000 next year so for them to
keep getting that $100,000 they have to
spend it all so what they'll do is
they're like well what do we need to
spend on all those chairs look old let's
just put them to the side we're buying a
whole new set we need new this we need
new that and you would hope that they
use it on the infrastructure but most of
it is like stupid ass things it's no
different than having your own business
too because that was one of the I think
for me biggest shock it's like if I
don't spend this money it's gone so then
it's like okay what do I need I need I
guess I need more cameras I guess I need
new sound equipment new whatever the
[__] and in the meantime I could have
used that to hire people to grow my
business but there's no incentive for
that like the the the realest incentive
I could get is just buying more [__]
from my business spend money to save
money it's so wild yeah it's pretty
crazy but yeah I think that those are
the things I I wish I [__] knew way
earlier another thing would be Health um
a lot of the stuff there's just a lot of
misinformation out there and then also
we learn now that like a lot of the
governing agencies were just marketing
arms of a lot of businesses you know oh
like the food pyramid and [__] anti- red
meat propaganda right cuz they were
distracting from sugar cuz big sugar was
actually [__] up big sugar sounds
funny like that crazy to me that big
milk was the person of the food pyramid
big grain they're still going they still
going strong milk is like signing
influencers and [__] dude they got
what's her name that act the poor
actress the poor actress is just like I
F my baby milk and then everyone's like
yeah [__] you you [__] cut you [__]
cut oh it just happened I can't remember
the I want to be a milk influenc I'll
promote Fair life I like Fair life oh
dude hook us up fair life isn't that
like super protein milk oh yeah that's
the best nothing with gas baby who that
Sally Field can I uh can I give a hot
take something completely different heck
yeah hot take all right um I think when
I was younger I thought sex was such a
big deal it is what are you talking
about never mind then what the fck but
continue how hot is that
take but just the idea that like you
know by the time you're an adult adult
like really an adult or you've been
around the block and you're just kind of
oh like girls wanted just as much or
like at the end of the day like it's
something that like was a big deal to
you like at like a week later maybe
they're not even thinking about it at
all blah blah
blah it's so casual for the rest of the
[__] world but you make it such a big
deal in your head when you're younger
and I feel like that stopped me from
experiencing so many different fun
situations that you would never allow
yourself to experience as an adult later
anyway so like should have had way more
sex dude yeah we should have just had
way more sex 100% my body counts so low
cuz of this propaganda [__] it's so
[__] low I think about it every day I
big milk big
milk I think when you were younger
though it's so hard to get that you
would [__] do you would stay up till
the middle of the night all right that's
it it's 2:00 we're going to go sneak out
whatever you would go through and all
[__] the back of a car like whatever
now I'm just like I'm too tired to go
hook up sounds exhausting know like I
think the older you get you're just like
I don't want to [__] [__] [__] in a
car so when I [__] in a car right I'm
6'4 and A2 my a Mini Cooper my knee hits
the belt buckle the [__] thing and
and I got to get over here and then like
you know my leg's falling asleep and I'm
like this is not fun yeah but when
you're 19 you're just like I can't wait
but there was something like magical
about you know the the conquest for sex
is such a thing that like gets
romanticized and even like comically
drawn up in like movies and [__] there
is something funny about being with your
boys and making a big deal out of it
like and then they come back and you're
like did you do it and then you're like
yes they did it and then everyone knows
she's a [__] after that that's and
that's the most satisfying part for us
right it's the [__] sh that's the part
that we like hey I wasn't talking about
women we're still talking about
financial literacy right yeah yeah yeah
mostly he saved money high five
he didn't have to take her to dinner cuz
she's a real [__] real AR kind of girl
AR kind of gal hey but 10 years too late
though dude for real imagine we all got
Bitcoin like 2014 I think about that
[__] all the time did you have a [__]
bunch of ethereum too 2012 I had my
first 1.3 Bitcoin in
2012 suck my dick [__] I've been early
to everything deal with it deal with it
you you can't but you should you're such
a wrestling heel I've I've always been
early to all this deal with it you can't
though adopter oh you know what's what's
one of the typical ones though that's
like you find out too late and I think
it works transitively on both sides is
the point of view of your parent versus
the point of view of the kid oh true
like how your parents saw you and how
when your parents realize how you saw
them like it's true that comes pretty
[__] late how how' it come to you it
comes faster if your parents like speak
[__] full English huh I
bet who you met he resents you Steve dad
spoke yelling by the way my dad spoke
yelling actually I'm just hypothetically
I'm just speaking openly just so you
know so I got this care my dad spoke I'm
going to take it out on my on on my
mother that's what my dad spoke I mean
like when when you're especially when
you're a teenager like my teen years
were pretty [__] bad and I was always
just like like the wall of not
understanding why your parents are doing
things you're just mad about it is like
pretty strong and I think like once it
breaks down it's like those years are
over already anyway like I'm out of the
house when I be became a parent I was
like damn my parents are extra
stupid cuz you're like this is easy what
the [__] cuz I thought it would be one
of those where like cuz like growing up
like my parents would always tell me man
once you have a kid you're going to
understand where all this is coming from
and then are Hicks and then when I got
uh yeah and when I had when I had a kid
like I understand the the impulsive and
initial
emotion but the execution I'm like damn
you guys thought that would work huh
you're a [__] idiot that's that's a
good strategy I think that's crazy
that's what's interesting about is like
I didn't I don't think that my parents
were right the funny thing is like and
now I just understand how they were
wrong but then I let that uh reaction to
their wrong decisions uh govern my
decisions that I made as a youth which I
think was the part that was [__] up
like I could have just went my parents
just don't you know they're they just
don't understand it this particular way
but I didn't have to overreact this is
what productive people do I think cuz
like you wouldn't have turned out the
way you did if not for your parents very
true not a chance and you Rose above a
lot of things and like you never make
excuses for anything I've never heard
you make an excuse ever ever I've seen a
lot of reasons why you maybe could use
use excuses you don't like I think that
you are just a productive person so you
push through with like I'm b anyway [__]
you and I think that that's because of
your my parents and that's something I'm
very grateful for actually they gave you
the environment of trauma and for you to
resist just again yeah it's hard it's
Lally it's a formative environment it's
like dude the way stars are [__] made
dude you know like it's productive as
hell yeah but it's like now you were you
know given those cards you were dealt
those cards and then it's depending on
you how how you play it so it's like if
you didn't have those struggles then
your characteristics would have been
completely different that's what's funny
it's like that's one thing that's almost
meant to be too late like it's almost
that's the point yeah the point is that
you go oh [__] no way and some of us
take much longer to learn than others I
think and the only sacrifice is a good
relationship with your parents yeah but
that that shit's always shaky though
isn't it but it's a two-way street man I
think like my mom had a lot of growth so
she was a stubborn [__] [__] but I
think she came around and and and it's a
it's a two-way street like both of us
were like oh [__] okay let's talk about
it you know cuz even until this day if I
get a text from my mom and I see it just
her name I'm
like okay but let's get to like a really
balanced place cuz I don't want to be my
initial response MH and then like okay
this is how this is how I can continue a
healthy relationship but I wish it
wasn't like that I wish it was like it
could be I'm so grateful for all the
things you taught me but all the things
I am grateful for instead of paying it
back to her I just try to give it to TAA
that's the best though but I also like
but then I also like feel like I'm not a
good son cuz like I'm I'm not paying the
love back to her either you know that
mean she did a good job you're always in
debt to her and you're doing good to her
grand yeah that's true but also hate her
guts yeah you don't really hate her not
exactly not hate hate you don't you
don't isolate her or or you would she's
I mean her I might even pick cilantro
over her I don't know hey but I mean
there are a lot of sons out there who
love their mom and wouldn't buy a house
for him that's true you you would do
that there's also a lot of sons out
there you do it with this face if it's
far away
yeah if it's far away I would I wouldn't
buy her house in Vegas I buy her house
[__] but you're you're still not
completely removed from it you know what
I mean like it's still there there's a
million times I want to tell my dad how
much I love him and how much I respect a
lot of things about him and stuff like
that but then I just think about all the
times he hung up on me growing up I
don't want to put myself out there and
just get hung up on again but yeah dude
your dad doesn't want to hear that [__]
though as soon as you compliment him
self-preservation yeah I just think
about that all the time like oh but I be
putting myself out there so much I know
I think the same thing like I think I'm
about to tell my dad I love you and then
I I hear him go okay like cuz that's how
he would be I'd be like oh I love you
Dad be like well
okay Ryan must be gone that's my old man
I I'd be calling I'm growing up like Hey
Dad like there's a what's what's going
on what's going on is this important uh
you know okay got to go bye and it's
like yeah yeah yeah we were so close
right and he's like [__] kids man but
that's but that's the thing the ability
to laugh about it is something that I
also wanted back then but I was only mad
yeah and I think that's the part that
was too and that's what this community
group's about exactly yeah we share our
trauma therapy dude JK news is
[__] I think those tools would have
been good at an early age like
processing information being able to
understand how to control your emotions
like normal [__] functions of like
how do you like work this body yeah how
do I make make it through life and [__]
yeah mhm with as little scars as
possible seeing the humor in all the
[__] disasters is probably the
greatest [__] it's a talent and skill
and then but that only comes after
you've already done all the incorrect
[__] after you [__] up bu yeah yeah and
it's
toxic so well seeing it all is humorous
humor yeah yeah that is true too what's
toxic about it very toxic I heard about
it oh is it is it cuz it's not an cuz
you shouldn't joke about it it has
misogynistic Roots I heard about but
we're toxic allies it's different that's
it there's probably white supremacy
roots in there too adjacent
tox Jason hey man toxic ooze is what
made the Ninja Turtles so count me out
and Shredder though and Shredder and
Shredder you piece of [__] you have it
both ways razar and B bopping Rock
Steady you
[__]
for